>>> BRAND NEW CNN REPORTING AND
A BIG CHANGE IN DONALD TRUMP'S
LEGAL TEAM.
TWO SOURCES TELLING CNN CHRIS
KIEZ, THE FORMER FLORIDA
SOLICITOR GENERAL WHO JUST
STARTED REPRESENTING THE
PRESIDENT A FEW WEEKS AGO IS
BEING SIDELINED FROM THE
MAR-A-LAGO DOCUMENTS CASE.
KAITLAN, WHAT HAPPENED?
>> IT HASN'T BEEN LONG SINCE HE
WAS BROUGHT ON TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S TEAM, THE FORMER
SOLICITOR GENERAL.
THAT'S PART OF WHY HE WAS
BROUGHT IN.
MAINLY CENTERED IN FLORIDA.
DESPITE BEING BROUGHT ON TO HELP
WITH THIS MAR-A-LAGO CASE, I'M
TOLD HE'S BASICALLY BEEN
SIDELINED FROM DEALING WITH THE
DOCUMENTS INVESTIGATION AND IS
NOT ACTUALLY LEADING THE LEGAL
TEAM'S EFFORTS WHEN IT COMES TO
THIS INVESTIGATION.
I AM TOLD HE DOES STILL REMAIN
ON THE LEGAL TEAM.
HE MAY BE WORKING ON SOME OF THE
OTHER INVESTIGATIONS THAT TRUMP
IS DEALING WITH.
JOHN, WE KNOW THERE'S SEVERAL OF
THOSE INCLUDING THE ONES DEALING
WITH THE CIVIL LAWSUIT IN NEW
YORK, LOOKING INTO TRUMP'S
BUSINESS PRACTICES, THE JANUARY
6th INVESTIGATION BASED OUT OF
WASHINGTON, D.C.
A LOT OF INVESTIGATIONS HE COULD
POTENTIALLY WORK ON.
IT'S NOTABLE HE'S NOT LEADING
THE EFFORTS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
MAR-A-LAGO DOCUMENTS
INVESTIGATION.
PART OF THAT REASON IS BECAUSE
HE WAS HIRED WITH A $3 MILLION
PRICE TAG.
THAT IS WHAT WAS PAID FOR BY
TRUMP'S OUTSIDE CAMPAIGN ARM
THAT WAS DEALING WITH THAT $3
MILLION PAYCHECK THAT CHRIS KISE
ASKED FOR UP FRONT.
THAT'S SOMETHING NOTABLE BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY TRUMP HAS DEVELOPED
THIS REPUTATION FOR NOT ALWAYS
PAYING HIS LEGAL FEES.
WE SHOULD NOTE, JOHN, THIS
COMES, AS WE REACHED OUT TO A
TRUMP SPOKESMAN.
THEY TOLD US ON THE RECORD CHRIS
KISE'S ROLE AS AN IMPORTANT
MEMBER OF TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM
REMAINS UNCHANGED AND ANY
SUGGESTION OTHERWISE IS UNTRUE.
HE IS NOT LEADING THE WAY ON THE
MAR-A-LAGO INVESTIGATION.
IT'S NOT PRECISELY EXPLAINED WHY
HE IS NO LONGER GOING TO BE
MAINLY DEALING WITH THAT.
THAT'S PRECISELY WHAT HE WAS
BROUGHT ON TO DEAL WITH WITH HIS
EXPERIENCE IN FLORIDA LAW, BUT
NOW EFFECTIVELY SIDELINED FROM
THE MAR-A-LAGO DOCUMENTS
INVESTIGATION.